hi youtube this is to cyllage
representing aravind eye care system and
moderate South India this is whole issue
of ethics whether the business community
should adopt some of the ethics at least
as stated in the health care community
as the doctors and others my personal
opinion is yes it should I think we also
need together both he and I front of
practice rather than beings as the that
there he pocket is having taken me but
the core of it is how do you create
Goodwin paradigm Oh God for your
customer and in the case of health care
for the patient and the doctor the case
of difference within the business and
the customer how do we engage in the
process that is non explorative and the
truly adds value go to the customer and
for the business in a way that it
mutually synergizes and to me this
should follow the code foundation for
the development of such as it extreme
work so at this one I wouldn't be able
to get into details of spelling it out I
think that's a much larger debate
batting I strongly feel creating this
bin velocity as a paradigm or the
foundation is it is the way to go